Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Katrina: 看这光好吗你问他
Katrina: Look at this light, is it good? Ask him.
Katrina: 这边光好吗
Katrina: Is the light here good?
Katrina: 那我要带眼睛
Katrina: Then I need to wear glasses.
Katrina: 我草
Katrina: Damn
Katrina: 呵呵我拿瓶饮料
Katrina: Haha, I'll grab a drink.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Katrina: 说什么呢我刚刚
Katrina: What was I just saying?
Shure:  啊没事没事
Shure: Ah, it's okay, it's okay.
Jake:那带什么眼镜
Jake: Then what glasses should you wear?
Alice:我觉得他不会
Alice: I don't think he will.
Shure的女友:我也想问啊
Shure's GF: I wanted to ask too.
女嘉宾:不行 接受不了你们俩个人
Female Guest: No way, I can't deal with you two.
Shure的女友:我也想问啊
Shure's GF: I wanted to ask too.
Shure:  没事那你给贡献一下也是可以的
Shure: It's okay, you can contribute a bit too.
Katrina: 还是晚上这种柔和一点的光拍的好看一点
Katrina: It's better to shoot with softer light at night.
Shure的女友:不可以
Shure's GF: No, you can't.
Shure的女友:我不可以
Shure's GF: I can't.
Shure:  草
Shure: Damn
Alice: Lucia
Lucia: 稍等一会我把这个
Lucia: Wait a minute, let me handle this.
Shure: 给你眼睛打个码
Shure: I'll blur your eyes.
Lucia:啊 找我吗
Lucia: Ah, are you looking for me?
Alice:你想参加我们的低智小视频吗
Alice: Do you want to join our silly little video?
Lucia:什么低智小视频
Lucia: What's a silly little video?
Alice:来来来 你让她看
Alice: Come on, show her.
女嘉宾:等一下我把这个连上
Female Guest: Wait a moment, let me connect this.
Jake: 这样你们这段声音可以闭掉是吧
Jake: So, you can mute this part, right?
Shure的女友:不 图像也不可以
Shure's GF: No, the image can't be shown either.
Jake: 图像也不可以
Jake: The image can't be shown either?
Lucia:哇 这个转圈好厉害哦
Lucia: Wow, this spin is amazing.
Shure: 图像可以可以
Shure: The image can be shown, it can be.
Jake: 为啥
Jake: Why?
Shure的女友:不可以
Shure's GF: No, it can't.
Jake: 行了全打码吧
Jake: Fine, blur everything then.
Lucia:你们怎么做到了
Lucia: How did you manage that?
Lucia:怎么拍的时候刚好边上没人呢
Lucia: How did you shoot with no one around?
Alice:巧合
Alice: Just a coincidence.
Shure的女友:声音其实没问题但是图像不可以
Shure's GF: The sound is actually fine, but the image can't be shown.
刘婷:退后 左右左往右跳步然后
Liuting: Step back, left, right, left, jump to the right, then...
Shure: 哦她要脸
Shure: Oh, she wants face.
Jake:好好那也可以
Jake: Alright, that works too.
Lucia:哇
Lucia: Wow.
男嘉宾:咱俩聊聊
Male guest: Let's chat.
Jake:这是市场需要的
Jake: This is what the market needs.
Lucia:哇好厉害
Lucia: Wow, that's impressive.
Alice:受不了了
Alice: I can't take it anymore.
男嘉宾:第一视角第二视角
Male guest: First-person view, second-person view.
刘婷:要加入我们吗
Liu Ting: Want to join us?
Jake: 对 那确实
Jake: Yes, indeed.
男嘉宾:太有必要了
Male guest: It's really necessary.
Lucia:可以啊
Lucia: Sure.
刘婷:快 你学好吗
Liu Ting: Quick, did you learn it well?
Jake: 怎么
Jake: How?
我们那天跳舞应该找他们的哦
We should have asked them to dance with us that day.
Alice: 怎么记住啊
Alice: How to remember?
Alice:不是我们 是他这种低智视频
Alice: It's not us, it's those low-IQ videos.
女嘉宾:别别不要给我乱戴帽子
Female guest: No, no, don't label me randomly.
Alice: 祖奶
Alice: Grandma.
Jake: 来来来我要看我要看
Jake: Come on, come on, I want to see, I want to see.
Jake: 导演把导演版拿出来
Jake: Director, bring out the director's cut.
刘婷:拍低智 过来 行
Liu Ting: Shoot the low-IQ stuff, come on, deal.
Alice:能不能教教我呀 我记不住
Alice: Can you teach me? I can't remember.
刘婷:没事
Liu Ting: It's okay.
刘婷:背对着他
Liu Ting: Face him.
Alice: 背对着他 背对啊
Alice: Face him, face him, right?
刘婷:背对着他
Liu Ting: Face him.
刘婷:然后
Liu Ting: Then...
Alice:这样啊哈哈哈哈
Alice: Like this? Hahaha.
刘婷:在
Liu Ting: Yes.
刘婷:ok
Liu Ting: Ok.
Alice:这样
Alice: Like this?
刘婷:这样 然后你直到啊一声
Liu Ting: Like this, and then you scream "ah."
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
刘婷:开始
Liu Ting: Start.
女嘉宾:起事
Female guest: Initiate.
Lucia:起
Lucia: Start.
Lucia:这是咱今天晚上保留节目吗
Lucia: Is this the highlight of tonight's show?
刘婷:对 然后你
Liu Ting: Yes, then you...
刘婷:呃
Liu Ting: Uh...
Alice:不是
Alice: No.
刘婷:这是我们的
Liu Ting: This is ours.
Jack: 可以是可以是
Jack: It could be, it could be.
Lucia:可以是可以是
Lucia: It could be, it could be.
Alice:别
Alice: Don't.
Jake: 挺好挺好的
Jake: It's pretty good, pretty good.
Lucia:来我帮你拍
Lucia: Come, I'll help you take a photo.
刘婷:AI识别不出来了怎么办
Liu Ting: What should we do if AI can't recognize it?
Jake: 最好让它识别出来对
Jake: It's best if it can recognize it, right.
Lucia:这个怎么
Lucia: How does this...
Lucia:现在就是开了
Lucia: It's on now.
Lucia:你要不要先调一下这些各种 参数之类的这些
Lucia: Do you want to adjust these parameters and stuff first?
男嘉宾:最近东方没找你
Male Guest: Has Dongfang contacted you recently?
Katrina:  没 他上次问我那什么方向以后
Katrina: No, after he asked me about that direction last time...
Katrina: 就没找过我了
Katrina: He hasn't contacted me again.
Lucia:你觉得哪里好看你就站哪里就行
Lucia: Just stand wherever you think looks good.
Katrina:  还没怎么去了解呢
Katrina: I haven't really looked into it yet.
Katrina:  我应该是做容器那一块
Katrina: I should be working on containers.
Katrina: 也就容器那一块
Katrina: Just containers.
男嘉宾：之前老师跟我说多了个方向让我可以选
Male Guest: Before, my professor told me there was an extra direction I could choose.
Katrina: 哪个浙大老师吗
Katrina: Which professor from Zhejiang University?
Katrina: 图形学不是山大的强项吗
Katrina: 那个好像不太好就业
Katrina: That field doesn't seem to have good job prospects.
Katrina: 图形图
Katrina: Graphics...
Shure的女友:就是从我带猫回家的时候然后我爸妈说
Shure: When I brought the cat home, my parents said...
男嘉宾:那可能是游戏公司嗯
Male Guest: It could be a gaming company.
Katrina:  嗯嗯 可以去游戏公司 但是
Katrina: Yeah, you can go to a gaming company, but...
Shure的女友:OK啊我回家
Shure: OK, I went home...
Shure的女友:我带个小朋友回家
Shure: And brought a little friend home.
Katrina:  可以啊
Katrina: Sure.
Shure的女友:然后回家之后我妈说我就知道
Shure: And after I got home, my mom said she knew it.
Lucia:为啥是连拍
Lucia: Why is it taking continuous shots?
Alice: 啊我觉得太抽象了
Alice: Ah, I think it's too abstract.
Lucia: 拍了好多张
Lucia: It took so many pictures.
Katrina: 这光要开闪光灯吗
Katrina: Should we turn on the flash for this light?
Lucia:这个光感好像不太用
Lucia: The light sensitivity seems fine without it.
Alice:啊 不是这个
Alice: Ah, not this one.
Katrina: 如果想让脸要亮一点的
Katrina: If you want the face to be brighter...
男嘉宾:脸亮点可以还行
Male Guest: A brighter face is fine.
Lucia:就是这样感觉还行
Lucia: Yeah, it feels fine like this.
男嘉宾:可以开一下闪
Male Guest: Can you turn on the flash?
Jack: 但是这个
Jack: But this...
Jack: 但是这个它本体是不带闪光灯的
Jack: But this device doesn't come with a flash.
Lucia:雨轩看一下
Lucia: Yuxuan, take a look.
Jack: 是不带闪光灯的呀
Jack: It doesn't come with a flash.
男嘉宾:你没有你没有闪吗
Male Guest: You don't have a flash?
Jack: 显然没有哦
Jack: Obviously not.
Lucia:哦没按
Lucia: Oh, I didn't press it.
Lucia: 要再来一张吗
Lucia: Do you want to take another one?
Lucia: 你看你想站哪
Lucia: See where you want to stand.
Alice:我再记一会
Alice: I'll remember it for a bit longer.
刘婷:来给我背一遍啊
Liu Ting: Come on, recite it for me.
男嘉宾:看来她们后面要跳舞
Male Guest: Looks like they're going to dance later.
男嘉宾:让他把这张帘放下他们后面会动
Male Guest: Let him lower that curtain, they'll move behind it.
Lucia:对对对我也想说
Lucia: Yes, yes, I was thinking the same.
Lucia:你这个入镜的刚好都是些可乐和酒
Lucia: Your shot just captures some cola and alcohol.
Lucia:显得你特别像一个调酒师或者什么的
Lucia: Makes you look like a bartender or something.
男嘉宾:啊可以可以
Male Guest: Oh, sure, sure.
Katrina:  这一块还有挺有氛围感的
Katrina: This spot has a good vibe.
男嘉宾:我给你拍一个
Male Guest: Let me take a picture for you.
Lucia:你本来就这么大
Lucia: Were you always this big?
Lucia:哈哈不是我摄影技术问题
Lucia: Haha, it's not my photography skills.
Shure的女友:没有我就是感觉
Shure: No, I just feel...
Lucia:哈哈 跑了 哈
Lucia: Haha, ran away, haha.
Alice: 我又不用分散
Alice: I don't need to be distracted.
Lucia:跑了相机不好相相机没拍出你的这个
Lucia: Ran away, the camera didn't capture your...
Lucia:这个这个英姿飒爽是吧
Lucia: Your heroic bearing, right?
Lucia:哈哈哈 这咋 哎
Lucia: Haha, what's this, oh.
Katrina:  我拿相
Katrina: I'll take it.
Lucia:相机没拍出你的英姿飒爽
Lucia: The camera didn't capture your heroic bearing.
Alice: 你你要不要参与我们
Alice: Do you want to join us?
Alice:脸 哈哈哈Lucia你来嘛
Alice: Come on, Lucia, join us.
Alice: 我是摸屁股这个
Alice: I'm the one touching the butt.
Alice: 哈哈哈不是哈哈哈哈
Alice: Haha, no, haha.
Shure: 啊没有没有
Shure: Oh, no, no.
Alice:你是哈哈那个
Alice: You're the one, haha.
刘婷:这是不是太近了
Liu Ting: Is this too close?
Lucia:如何一句话劝退别人是吗
Lucia: How to discourage someone in one sentence, right?
Katrina:  哈哈哈还教摆pose
Katrina: Haha, teaching poses too.
Katrina:  哈哈哈还有还有助理帮你调整
Katrina: Haha, there's even an assistant to help you adjust.
刘婷:或者我们投票吧
Liu Ting: Or we can vote.
刘婷:就是可能会伤害他的眼睛
Liu Ting: It might hurt his eyes.
Lucia:伤害他的眼镜 啊 OK
Lucia: Hurt his glasses? Ah, OK.
Alice: 就这样蹦来蹦去吗
Alice: Just jumping around like this?
Alice: 我连个兜都没有
Alice: I don't even have a pocket.
Alice: 这别我腰上的
Alice: This is tied around my waist.
刘婷:拿着  还有一个就是这个
Liu Ting: Hold this. And there's also this one.
Lucia:啊 不过这个就是容易掉下来
Lucia: Ah, but this one is easy to drop.
Alice:他抖音上全是这种低智小视频
Alice: His TikTok is full of these low-IQ videos.
刘婷:对像你
Liu Ting: Yeah, just like you.
Lucia:那刚那个人是你吗
Lucia: Was that person you earlier?
刘婷:哦我网上收集的低智数据
Liu Ting: Oh, I collected those low-IQ data online.
Alice: 低智太奶这就是
Alice: Low-IQ and cute, that's what it is.
Katrina:  这应该把富士带来
Katrina: We should have brought Fuji.
Katrina:  哈哈富士拍出来更好看
Katrina: Haha, Fuji photos look better.
Katrina:  哦哦对
Katrina: Oh, oh, right.
Lucia:迅速进入角色
Lucia: Quickly get into character.
Katrina: 就唱歌
Katrina: Just sing.
刘婷:你看你看
Liu Ting: Look, look.
Katrina:  感觉太皮了就是
Katrina: Feels too playful.
Katrina:  没有一个确定的活动也不是特别正式
Katrina: Without a set activity, it's not very formal.
Katrina:  就大家吃喝
Katrina: Just everyone eating and drinking.
刘婷:你要有
Liu Ting: You need to have...
Alice:有
Alice: I have...
Lucia:响亮的答案没有
Lucia: A loud answer, no.
刘婷:要有要有要有
Liu Ting: You need to, you need to, you need to.
Katrina: 我 我想
Katrina: I, I want to...
Katrina:  我想拿这个拍照
Katrina: I want to take a picture with this.
Katrina:  哈哈哈我可以拿他那个给我拍照
Katrina: Hahaha, can I use his to take my picture?
Katrina:  你给我看
Katrina: Show me.
Jack: 可以啊
Jack: Sure.
Jake: 你要变身
Jake: You need to transform.
刘婷:你看一下位置
Liu Ting: Check the position.
Katrina:  靖康导师导师我可以拿这个拍张照吗
Katrina: Instructor Jingkang, can I use this to take a picture?
Jake:啊 没问题你自己改 你随便改
Jake: Ah, no problem, you can change it however you like.
Alice:那我不就是最明显的那个了
Alice: Then I will be the most obvious one.
Jake:你随便改一下都可以
Jake: You can change it however you like.
Katrina: 哈哈哈看哪光好
Katrina: Hahaha, check where the light is good.
Jack: 这这黄哪光都那样
Jack: With this yellow, the light is the same everywhere.
Jack: 那可以
Jack: That works.
Jake:那我搬出来
Jake: Then I'll move out.
Alice: 那这边不就没地了
Alice: But then there won't be any space here.
Shure的女友:哦我碰到你了吗
Shure's GF: Oh, did I bump into you?
Katrina:  这光好吗面这
Katrina: Is the lighting good here?
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈我是导演
Katrina: Hahaha, I'm the director.
Katrina:  哇哦哈哈哈
Katrina: Wow, hahaha.
Lucia:哇哦哈哈
Lucia: Wow, haha.
Katrina:  红点是什么
Katrina: What's the red dot?
Katrina: 啊 对焦
Katrina: Ah, focus.
Katrina:  太专业了
Katrina: So professional.
Katrina: 但就第一天用了知道吗这个后来就没有
Katrina: But we only used it on the first day, you know? Then never again.
Alice:哈哈我以为是想高智人生
Alice: Haha, I thought you wanted to be a genius.
Jack: 你们难道你们并不是
Jack: You mean you're not?
Katrina:  我们太随便了
Katrina: We're too casual.
Katrina:  我以为第一天很正式
Katrina: I thought the first day would be very formal.
Katrina: 你觉得怎样自信你说
Katrina: How do you feel about being confident, you say?
Katrina: 这样 放这边
Katrina: Like this, put it here.
Katrina:  对啊
Katrina: Yeah.
Shure: 特意让我去打卡一下的是吧
Shure: You specifically want me to punch in, right?
Jake: 就这样录一下你们祥是哈哈哈哈
Jake: Just record you guys like this, hahaha.
Shure的女友:no no no no
Shure's GF: No no no no.
Lucia:然后下一个是我是吧
Lucia: And then it's my turn next, right?
Katrina: 回家
Katrina: Go home.
Lucia:啊这样子
Lucia: Ah, like this.
Lucia:然后还是接着动啊哈哈
Lucia: And then keep moving, haha.
Alice: 玩不了一点哈哈哈
Alice: Can't even play a little, hahaha.
刘婷:存个草稿
Liu Ting: Save a draft.
Jake: 呃我拉插线板会长一点
Jake: Uh, I'll pull the power strip, it'll be longer.
Jack: 他色温可以调吗
Jack: Can the color temperature be adjusted?
Katrina: 哎他他有补光灯
Katrina: Hey, it has a fill light.
Jack: 那就这样了
Jack: Then that's it.
Jake: 好嘞 能强点是吧
Jake: Alright, can it be stronger?
Jack: 不是 色温可以重新
Jack: No, you can adjust the color temperature again.
刘婷:存草稿吧存草稿
Liu Ting: Save the draft, save the draft.
Alice:哎呦 我笑死了
Alice: Oh my gosh, I'm dying of laughter.
Katrina: 看补光灯有效果没
Katrina: Check if the fill light works.
Lucia:没有
Lucia: No.
Lucia:响亮的答复 没有
Lucia: Loud and clear, no.
Katrina: 哇我像导演哎
Katrina: Wow, I look like a director.
Katrina:  这样拍我头发好黄好黄 嗯
Katrina: Filming like this, my hair looks so yellow, so yellow. Hmm.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Katrina:  我我是把头发披下来还是把它扎起来
Katrina: Should I leave my hair down or tie it up?
Katrina:  你这是用哪个相机 dell
Katrina: Which camera are you using, Dell?
Katrina:  哪个
Katrina: Which one?
Katrina: 我看看DOS DQS 哦
Katrina: Let me see DOS DQS, oh.
Alice: 就没有那么丢人
Alice: It wouldn't be that embarrassing.
Katrina:  他们之前说那个XXM好看啊
Katrina: They said that XXM looked good before.
刘婷:怎么能这样呢
Liu Ting: How can they be like this?
Lucia:怎么能这样呢
Lucia: How can they be like this?
Lucia:说的好像我不愿意跟你一起丢人一样
Lucia: It's like I don't want to be embarrassed with you.
Alice:哈哈哈但是我不愿意拉你一起丢人
Alice: Haha, but I don't want to drag you into being embarrassed.
Katrina: ego life
Katrina: Ego life.
Alice:但是丢人的话我觉得就可以
Alice: But if it's embarrassing, I think it's fine.
Katrina: 那这样的话啊 人
Katrina: In that case, people...
Jack: 哎呀
Jack: Oh no.
Katrina: 点点头
Katrina: Nodding.
Jack: 实际上眼镜上泛着那
Jack: Actually, the glasses reflect that...
Alice: 那那我们这样
Alice: So, we'll do it like this.
Lucia:眼睛上泛着诡异的光
Lucia: The eyes reflect a strange light.
女嘉宾:眼镜上面有光
Female Guest: There's light on the glasses.
Lucia:可还行
Lucia: Not bad.
Lucia:哪边
Lucia: Which side?
Alice:好
Alice: Okay.
Alice:来吧
Alice: Come on.
Katrina:  一起播
Katrina: Let's broadcast together.
Tasha:好吧
Tasha: Okay.
Katrina:  我们一起拍 拍拍
Katrina: We'll shoot together.
Alice:来
Alice: Come on.
Katrina: 我 拿这个咱信就是演员
Katrina: I'll take this, we are actors.
Alice: 怎怎么摆
Alice: How should we pose?
Katrina:  我们仨自已决定吧
Katrina: Let's decide among the three of us.
Lucia:可以可以
Lucia: Sure, sure.
Lucia:交叉比等一下
Lucia: Cross and wait a moment.
Alice: 我是危险中心
Alice: I'm the center of danger.
Lucia:手里一直揣着这个
Lucia: Holding this all the time.
Katrina: 我也加入
Katrina: I'm joining too.
Lucia:刚才擦手用餐巾纸擦
Lucia: Just now, using a napkin to wipe hands.
Lucia:咱俩还可以这样
Lucia: We can still do this.
Katrina:  ok
Katrina: Ok.
Lucia:算了有点乱了
Lucia: Never mind, it's a bit messy.
Alice: 有点抽象
Alice: That's a bit abstract.
Lucia:等一下我扶一下眼镜
Lucia: Wait a second, let me adjust my glasses.
Lucia:我这眼镜往下滑
Lucia: My glasses keep slipping down.
Katrina: 这光补光打出来啥样
Katrina: How does this lighting look?
Alice:累了
Alice: I'm tired.
男嘉宾：你可算不闭眼了露西亚
Male Guest: Finally, you stopped closing your eyes, Lucia.
Lucia:哎这个光很好
Lucia: Oh, this light is great.
Lucia:有补光灯就是不一样
Lucia: Having a fill light really makes a difference.
女嘉宾:一会伸手不见五指
Female Guest: Soon, you won't be able to see your hand in front of you.
Katrina:  什么环节
Katrina: What segment is this?
Katrina:  现在是after party阿
Katrina: Is it the after party now?
Lucia:after party
Lucia: After party.
Lucia:不是不是修硕要
Lucia: No, no, Shure wants...
Shure的女友:没有点正经音乐
Shure's GF: There's no proper music.
Katrina: 唱歌
Katrina: Singing.
Alice:你要从这到那要多久
Alice: How long will it take you to get from here to there?
Katrina:  啊修硕 唱歌
Katrina: Ah, Shure, sing a song.
Lucia:不是修硕要跳舞来着的吗
Lucia: Wasn't Shure supposed to dance?
Jake: 对啊修硕跳舞唱歌
Jake: Yeah, Shure should dance and sing.
Katrina:  修硕跳舞
Katrina: Shure, dance.
Lucia:不是修硕要干好多事来着吗
Lucia: Wasn't Shure supposed to do a lot of things?
Katrina:  哈哈哈核心主力吗
Katrina: Hahaha, the main performer, huh?
Shure:  我怕回去他不认我了
Shure: I'm afraid they won't recognize me when I go back.
Katrina: 哈哈你跳个舞她也跟你和好了
Katrina: Haha, just dance, and they'll be fine with you.
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Shure: 他分在哪跳啊
Shure: Where should I dance?
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina: 咱俩跳 对
Katrina: Let's dance together. Yeah.
Shure的女友:哎 你别说他小时候学过
Shure's GF: Hey, don't forget he learned it when he was young.
Katrina:  他学什么舞种
Katrina: What kind of dance did he learn?
Shure的女友:你问他咯
Shure's GF: Ask him.
Katrina:  不会学拉丁吧
Katrina: Did he learn Latin dance?
Shure:  没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Tasha: 杨老板把我感下来记我来记录生活
Tasha: Jake, let me write down my life experiences.
Nicous: 对
Nicous: Yes.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 好的他要给我开3万块钱一个月
Tasha: Alright, he's going to pay me 30,000 a month.
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Tasha: 你知道吗
Tasha: You know that?
Katrina:  你再说他要破防要破防
Katrina: If you keep talking, he's going to lose his temper.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Tasha: 他说他要给我开3万块一个月
Tasha: He said he wants to pay me 30,000 a month.
Shure的女友:他刚刚已经没理我
Shure's GF: He just ignored me.
刘婷:哦哟 慢点慢点
Liu Ting: Oh, slow down, slow down.
Katrina: 抽一根
Katrina: Have a smoke.
Jake:拜拜拜拜
Jake: Bye bye, bye bye.
Katrina: 他要走了吗
Katrina: Is he leaving?
Katrina: 他们走了吗
Katrina: Did they leave?
Jake: 对 两个gester送走
Jake: Yeah, sent off with two gestures.
Katrina: 现在几点钟了
Katrina: What time is it now?
女嘉宾:现在7.30了
Female Guest: It's 7:30 now.
Katrina: 我们预计八点结束还没有唱一首歌
Katrina: We planned to finish at 8, but we haven't sung a song yet.
女嘉宾:让她唱一首结束呗
Female Guest: Let her sing one to end it.
女嘉宾:一首就5分钟
Female Guest: One song is just five minutes.
Katrina: 你还没表演你的才艺呢
Katrina: You haven't performed your talent yet.
Nicous: 可以啊
Nicous: Sure.
Katrina: 你的电钢琴啊
Katrina: Your electric piano.
Nicous: 太简单了
Nicous: That's too easy.
Nicous: 难忘今宵已经练好了
Nicous: I've already practiced "Unforgettable Tonight."
Jake: 还没开始呢就让我清场
Jake: Haven't even started yet and you want me to clear the stage.
Jake: 别忘了那三首歌啊 我靠 哈哈哈
Jake: Don't forget those three songs. Oh man, haha.
Katrina:  修硕
Katrina: Shure.
Jake: 修硕你选的三首歌了
Jake: Shure, the three songs you chose.
Katrina: 马上谈恋爱了
Katrina: About to fall in love.
Katrina: 一起唱呗
Katrina: Let's sing together.
Katrina: new boy这首
Katrina: This song "New Boy."
Shure:  修硕我们
Shure: Shure, us.
Katrina: 模特模特
Katrina: Model, model.
Shure: 收费啊收费
Shure: Charge a fee, charge a fee.
Shure的女友:拍你们不行吗
Shure's GF: Can't I take photos of you?
Jack: 你俩是唯一正经的情侣
Jack: You two are the only serious couple.
Shure: 什么叫正经
Shure: What's "serious"?
Shure: 你们这些回去都不能说是吧
Shure: You guys can't say anything when you go back, right?
Lucia:我们这都不是CP
Lucia: We're not even a couple.
Katrina: 我看用手机拍
Katrina: I think we should use a phone to take pictures.
Katrina:  我试试给你们拍一组壁纸出来
Katrina: I'll try to take some wallpaper shots for you.
Jake:两个ego币
Jake: Two ego coins.
Jake:蹲下去了这个就不行了
Jake: If you squat, it's not gonna work.
Shure:  怎怎么看摄影师
Shure: How do you look at the photographer?
女嘉宾:怎么看
Female Guest: How do you look?
男嘉宾:就你随便看个地方吧
Male Guest: Just look at any place you want.
男嘉宾:看地上然后你看啊
Male Guest: Look at the ground and then you see.
Katrina: 哈哈不准笑场
Katrina: Haha, no laughing!
Shure的女友:就是我们俩这个情况比较复杂
Nurse: The situation between us is quite complicated.
Jack: 什么情况比较复杂
Jack: What do you mean by complicated?
Jake:啊什么叫复杂什么叫复杂
Jake: What do you mean by complicated, what do you mean?
Jack: 什么叫复杂
Jack: What do you mean by complicated?
Katrina: 拍 拍 拍到非公开群里
Katrina: Film it, film it and post it to the private group.
男嘉宾:哪里复杂
Male Guest: What's complicated about it?
Shure的女友:sorry
Nurse: Sorry.
Shure的女友:不是他看我我看他
Nurse: It's just that he looks at me, and I look at him.
Jake: 你要给我们送一集多少信息
Jake: How much information are you going to give us?
Shure的女友:我们俩会笑场
Nurse: We both end up laughing.
Jack: 怎么复杂
Jack: How is it complicated?
Jake:咱能飙一下午咱能飙得了不
Jake: Can we keep this going all afternoon?
Jack: 复杂在哪
Jack: What's complicated about it?
Jake:咱能飙得了不
Jake: Can we keep this going?
Jack: 到时候到时候这涉及到一个问题
Jack: This brings up a question.
Jack: 为什么复杂然后发给修硕他
Jack: Why is it complicated? Then send it to Shure.
Jack: 发给修硕填填填答案呢
Jack: Send it to Shure to fill in the answers.
Katrina: 我靠 这不就是壁纸吗
Katrina: Wow, isn't this just a wallpaper?
Lucia:眼睛会有点反光是
Lucia: The eyes might reflect a bit.
Katrina:  哎真好看
Katrina: Wow, it's really pretty.
Katrina:  太好看了  太好看了
Katrina: So beautiful, so beautiful.
Jack: 一点都不想看见他们
Jack: I don't even want to see them.
Katrina:  羡慕了
Katrina: I'm so jealous.
男嘉宾:快快快
Male Guest: Hurry, hurry, hurry.
Jake:哎呀妈
Jake: Oh my god.
男嘉宾:来配合摄影师一下
Male Guest: Come on, cooperate with the photographer.
Jack: 这这个看法不太不太正常
Jack: This perspective doesn't seem quite normal.
Katrina: 你俩别整的像暧昧气一样行吗
Katrina: Can you two stop acting so flirty?
Jack: 你们俩搞得像你们俩
Jack: You two are acting like...
Jack: 现在还在害羞非常暧昧
Jack: You two are still shy and very flirty.
Jack: 所以是暧昧期吗
Jack: So are you in a flirty phase?
Katrina: 还老夫老妻了暧昧去
Katrina: You're like an old couple flirting.
Jack: 啊
Jack: Huh?
Jack: 看着也不像啊
Jack: Doesn't look like it.
Jake:多久了 我也不懂我也不懂
Jake: How long has it been? I don't get it, I don't get it.
男嘉宾:我也不懂我也很好奇
Male Guest: I don't get it either, I'm very curious.
Jake:回去你自己飙啊
Jake: You go back and figure it out yourself.
男嘉宾:最后两张
Jake: 哈哈哈 我是飙不了的
Jack: 到正到时问起就哎放
Shure的女友:OK
Jake:这玩意彪不了啦
Katrina: 理解不了
Jake:拍破防了 我草
Jake:拍到了吧是吧
Jake:反正我们是都录了
男嘉宾:没电了
Katrina: 摄影师不行了
Jake: 挺好
Lucia:对这张好像反光弱一些
Shure: 是的都是我们配的一环
Jake:我觉得是第一个学习机里有接吻片的
Jake: 第一视角接吻照片
Jack: 我刚我刚错过了什么
Jake:马上给他们看一眼
Shure:  所有那个学生会议都要邀请我俩去亲一下是吧
Jack: 我刚错过了什么
Tasha: 这里面有 上一张
Tasha: It's in here. Previous one.
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Shure:  对对对 上一张
Shure: Yeah, yeah, previous one.
Jake:我们第一张图片配合第一张图片就是这个哇
Jake: Our first picture matches the first picture, that's it.
Jack: 让我看看 来来来先先
Jack: Let me see. Come on, come on, first.
Katrina: 看看看
Katrina: Look, look, look.
Katrina:  拍到了吗看看
Katrina: Did you get it? Look.
Jack: 哦
Jack: Oh.
Jake:啊好妙啊
Jake: Ah, this is amazing.
Jack: 看了一下正点啊
Jack: Checked it out, it's on point.
Katrina: 哇
Katrina: Wow.
Katrina: 哇 来给我拍一张
Katrina: Wow, take a picture of me.
Jack: 分手一钱给到位也没问题
Jack: Breakup fee, as long as it's paid, no problem.
Nicous: 分手了也没有关系吗
Nicous: No problem even after breaking up?
Katrina:  是发群里吧
Katrina: Share it in the group, right?
Katrina:  发群里公开
Katrina: Post it publicly in the group.
Jack: 没问题 没问题
Jack: No problem, no problem.
Jake:没问题
Jake: No problem.
Shure的女友:要不然怎么会说情况很复杂呢
Nurse: Otherwise, why say the situation is complicated?
男嘉宾:有经验了都
Male guest: Gained some experience.
Katrina: 不是哥们不玩了走了
Katrina: Hey, I'm not playing anymore, I'm leaving.
Lucia:然后我直接转发到群里
Lucia: Then I'll just forward it to the group.
Jake: 妙
Jake: Brilliant.
Jake: 哎都行听你的
Jake: Alright, whatever you say.
Katrina:  餐巾纸呢
Katrina: Where are the napkins?
Jack:  餐巾纸
Jack: Napkins.
Jack: 后面后面后面
Jack: Behind you, behind you.
Katrina: 没看见哦
Katrina: Can't see them.
男嘉宾:他可能真的限制了一些你的视野
Male Guest: Maybe something is blocking your view.
男嘉宾:你要拿一包新的
Male Guest: You need a new pack.
男嘉宾:你就拿这个
Male Guest: Just take this one.
男嘉宾:挺好掉地上他本来在这放
Male Guest: It fell on the ground, it was originally here.
Jack: 嘿嘿你要
Jack: Hey, do you want...
Jack: 你要新的
Jack: Do you want a new one?
Jack: 还是要就抽两张
Jack: Or just take two sheets?
Katrina: 哦我知道了
Katrina: Oh, got it.
Shure: 好渴望哈哈哈
Shure: So eager, hahaha.
Katrina: 受不了了
Narrator: Katrina can't take it anymore.
Katrina: 又被你刺激到
Katrina: You provoked me again.
Katrina: 今天晚上听一百遍
Katrina: I'll listen to it a hundred times tonight.
Katrina: 唯一哈哈no
Katrina: The only one, haha, no.
Katrina: 就是不行
Katrina: It's just not okay.
Katrina: 胆子小的一逼
Katrina: I'm such a scaredy-cat.
Katrina: 我说我胆子小的一逼
Katrina: I said I'm a scaredy-cat.
Shure: 哈哈哈谁啊
Shure: Hahaha, who?
Katrina: 什么东西啊
Katrina: What is it?
Katrina: 你们两个不要瞎说
Katrina: You two stop talking nonsense.
男嘉宾:发生了什么
Male Guest: What happened?
Katrina: 他们两天造谣呢
Katrina: They're spreading rumors.
Katrina: 我的roommate
Katrina: My roommates.
Shure:  所以我的iPad放哪了
Shure: So, where did I put my iPad?
Shure:  哎 我的iPad
Shure: Hey, my iPad.
Shure:  谁记得我的iPad放哪儿
Shure: Does anyone remember where I put my iPad?
Shure:  我的iPad放哪儿
Shure: Where's my iPad?
Jake:会有这种数据我靠
Jake: Is there such data? Damn.
Shure:  你有印象吗
Shure: Do you remember?
Lucia:你试试那个寻找我的iPhone的功能
Lucia: Try using the Find My iPhone feature.
Jake: 哦你在找吗
Jake: Oh, are you looking for it?
Lucia:不是
Lucia: No.
Shure: 没有我的iPad
Shure: My iPad is missing.
Lucia:修硕不是找不到
Lucia: Shure, it's not lost.
Shure:  忘记了放哪了
Shure: I forgot where I put it.
Lucia:我说可以试试寻找我的iPhone的功能
Lucia: I said you could try the Find My iPhone feature.
Jake: 咋的呀
Jake: What happened?
Jake: 不是这个不是这个薇薇的
Jake: No, this isn't it. This is Tasha's.
Lucia:这个应该是薇薇的吧
Lucia: This should be Tasha's, right?
Jake: 二楼没有吗
Jake: Not on the second floor?
Shure:  你有看到我的iPad吗
Shure: Did you see my iPad?
Shure的女友:在楼上
Shure's GF: It's upstairs.
Shure:  哦哦在架子上呢
Shure: Oh, it's on the shelf.
Shure的女友:在那个那个那个水池旁边
Shure's GF: It's by the sink.
Lucia:这两天这个网怎么老是这么差
Lucia: Why has the internet been so bad these past few days?
Jake:是我也发现了
Jake: Yeah, I noticed that too.
Katrina: 去二楼活动还是去哪活动啊
Katrina: Are we going to do activities on the second floor or somewhere else?
Jake:二楼活动
Jake: Second floor activities.
Shure: 二楼活动或者外面都行
Shure: Second floor or outside, both are fine.
Jake:或者外面都行
Jake: Or outside, that's fine too.
Jack: 都可以其实
Jack: Either is okay, actually.
Jake:看设备在哪
Jake: Depends on where the equipment is.
Katrina: 准备
Katrina: Get ready.
Katrina: 上才艺
Katrina: Let's show our talents.
Nicous: 我就撤退了
Nicous: I'm out of here.
Katrina: 撤退
Katrina: Retreat
Katrina: 什么撤退了
Katrina: Why are you retreating?
Lucia:哎你今天回学校吗
Lucia: Hey, are you going back to school today?
Shure: 谁把我音箱给拔了
Shure: Who unplugged my speaker?
Katrina: 哦快8点了
Katrina: Oh, it's almost 8 o'clock.
Katrina: 因为我们整体活动往后延了一个小时
Katrina: Because our overall activities were delayed by an hour.
Jake:我们不是6:40准时
Jake: Weren't we supposed to start at 6:40?
Jake:4.07准时开始是吗
Jake: Start promptly at 4:07, right?
Jake:确实
Jake: That's right.
Lucia:为什么大家都站着我坐着
Lucia: Why is everyone standing and I'm sitting?
Katrina: 上二楼坐
Katrina: Go sit on the second floor.
Jake:嗯没事没事
Jake: It's okay, it's okay.
Lucia:起立
Lucia: Stand up.
Katrina: 上二楼坐一会你在走
Katrina: Go sit on the second floor for a bit before you leave.
Shure: 等一下这个
Shure: Hold on, this...
Katrina: 那你那你明天还来吗你们
Katrina: Are you, are you coming tomorrow?
Katrina: 工作人员
Katrina: Staff
Katrina: 修硕说他明天不来了
Katrina: Shure said he's not coming tomorrow.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Shure: 我想今晚就
Shure: I want to tonight...
Shure: 因为leader要找我
Shure: Because the leader wants to see me.
Shure: 在上面吧
Shure: Upstairs, right?
Jake:哎呀要上去了
Jake: Oh, we need to go up.
Shure: 他在上面活动
Shure: He's having an event upstairs.
Tasha:怎么回事
Tasha: What's going on?
Jack: 既然你们都已经计划完了
Jack: Since you all have already planned it out.
Shure: 行
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 那在上面活动吧
Shure: Then let's do the event upstairs.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Shure: 虽然上面的氛围肯定稍逊色一点
Shure: Although the atmosphere upstairs might be a bit lacking.
Katrina: 加了点青提以后就
Katrina: Adding a bit of green grapes...
Katrina: 没那么苦了
Katrina: It's not that bitter anymore.
Katrina: 小红书 上面学的就是
Katrina: Learned this from Xiaohongshu...
Katrina: 那个叫什么
Katrina: What's it called again?
Katrina: 养乐多加青提
Katrina: Yakult with green grapes.
Jake:要插电板吗
Jake: Do you need a power strip?
Nicous: 可以用 可以用
Nicous: It's usable, it's usable.
Jake:不用了 好嘞
Jake: No need, alright then.
Nicous: 你音箱接上了没
Nicous: Did you connect the speaker?
Shure: 音箱他们都接一起了我记得
Shure: I remember they connected all the speakers together.
Shure: 对插这个
Shure: Yeah, plug this in.
Jack: 这这个是个啥呀
Jack: What is this?
Shure: 这就是个声卡
Shure: This is just a sound card.
Shure: 哎这要插线板
Shure: Oh, we need a power strip for this.
Shure: 谁把这个插线板拔下去了
Shure: Who unplugged the power strip?
Shure: 我打算就回去上两天班看看心情
Shure: I'm planning to go back to work for a couple of days to see how I feel.
Jake:我啊 拔下去的呀
Jake: It was me, I unplugged it.
Shure: 来吧来吧
Shure: Come on, come on.
Shure的女友:修 要琴吗
Shure: Do you need a piano?
Shure: 哎 要琴
Shure: Yeah, I need a piano.
Shure: 要钱嗯
Shure: Need money, yes.
Shure: 你先
Shure: You first.
Shure: 谢谢你
Shure: Thank you.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Jack: 来我给你主持一波
Jack: Come on, I'll host for you.
Nicous: 修硕你今晚不走了走了
Nicous: Shure, you're not leaving tonight, right?
Shure: 我
Shure: I...
Jake:啊你还要走啊
Jake: Ah, you're leaving?
Jake:你不能走啊
Jake: You can't leave!
Shure: 我不能走么
Shure: I can't leave?
Jake:你你也能走
Jake: You can leave too.
Shure: 我我主要
Shure: I, mainly...
Shure: 我主要想
Shure: I mainly want to...
Jake:想干嘛想想毕业
Jake: What do you want? To graduate?
Shure: 明天上班主要是
Shure: I have work tomorrow.
Nicous: 明天上班
Nicous: Work tomorrow?
Shure: 明天
Shure: Tomorrow.
Jake:来插线板
Jake: Bring the power strip.
Shure: 因为
Shure: Because...
Shure: 其实再再呆一天
Shure: Actually, staying one more day...
Shure: 我翘了一周班
Shure: I've skipped work for a week.
Shure: 我靠
Shure: Oh my...
Jack: 哦血亏2100 至少2100
Jack: Oh, that's at least 2100 lost.
Shure: 没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Jake:带薪翘班还是啥
Jake: Skipping work with pay or what?
Jack: 你给他300一天网易少给他300一天
Jack: You pay him 300 a day, NetEase pays him 300 less a day.
Shure: 没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Jake:哦这么回事
Jake: Oh, so that's how it is.
Shure: 网易就150
Shure: NetEase is just 150.
Shure: 我一天
Shure: Per day.
Jake:那你一直在我身上 对啊
Jake: Then you've been with me all along, right?
Lucia:哦 其实赚了
Lucia: Oh, so you actually earned more.
Shure: 而而且
Shure: And, and...
Jake:对啊 那你回去干嘛
Jake: Right, so why go back?
Jake:那你回去干嘛
Jake: So why go back?
Katrina: 明天待一天还有300呢
Katrina: If you stay one more day, you'll get another 300.
Shure: 也也也也有道理
Shure: Also, also makes sense.
Jack: 对啊那那那
Jack: Yeah, so...
Shure: 待一天吧待一天吧
Shure: Let's stay another day, let's stay another day.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure的女友:谁呀我啊
Unknown: Who? Me?
Katrina: 反正他说他也转正不了
Katrina: Anyway, he said he can't get a permanent position.
Shure的女友:啊
Unknown: Ah.
Katrina: 回家已经签了三访了
Katrina: Signed three visits already back home.
Shure: 等一下等一下
Shure: Wait, wait.
Jack: 既然都不能转正摸就摸吧
Jack: Since you can't get a permanent position, just slack off.
Shure: 来 来
Shure: Come on, come on.
Katrina: 何况这还300一天
Katrina: Besides, it's 300 a day.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Jake:确实 就是顾大来摸鱼啦
Jake: Yeah, just hire someone to slack off.
Jake:你们带着眼镜就行
Jake: You just need to wear glasses.
Shure: 来 我来我来
Shure: Here, I'll do it.
Jake:干啥都行
Jake: Do whatever you want.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Shure: 插上了
Shure: Plugged in.
Katrina: 拍一下我们老板
Katrina: Take a picture of our boss.
Katrina: 哈哈哈拍一下我们提倡摸鱼的老板
Katrina: Hahaha take a picture of our boss who encourages slacking off.
Katrina: 哈哈哈真好人
Katrina: Hahaha such a good person.
Katrina: 睡到11点不带叫你醒的
Katrina: Sleep till 11 without waking you up.
Jack: 是吗
Jack: Really?
Jack: 喂喂
Jack: Hello, hello.
Jake:咦 少个人少人是吧
Jake: Hey, someone is missing, right?
Jake:坐地上可以
Jake: You can sit on the floor.
Katrina: 少谁啊
Katrina: 薇薇啊
Katrina: Tasha?
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina: 哦还有那个
Katrina: Oh, and that...
Katrina: 柯欣是吗
Katrina: Is it Kexin?
Jake:柯欣
Jake: Kexin.
Jake:坐地上
Jake: Sit on the floor.
Shure: 来吧我在703
Shure: Come on, I'm in room 703.
Katrina: 哈哈哈我们没有排过任何一遍
Katrina: Hahaha we never rehearsed even once.
Katrina: 真的的可以吗
Katrina: Really, is it okay?
Shure: 可以
Shure: It's fine.
Jake:这是默契
Jake: It's the chemistry.
Jake:已经毕业了
Jake: We're already graduated.
Shure: 对就是默契
Shure: Yeah, it's the chemistry.
Jake:对这是提前培养的默契
Jake: Yeah, it's the chemistry developed in advance.
Katrina: 等等等薇薇他们回来要不要一起
Katrina: Wait, wait, should we wait for Tasha and the others to come back?
男嘉宾:难忘今宵
Male Guest: Unforgettable tonight.
男嘉宾:不如在这个时候
Male Guest: How about at this time...
男嘉宾:我们要留下来一种普通人
Male Guest: We leave behind something for ordinary people.
Katrina: 哈哈每天都要弹一遍
Katrina: Hahaha, we have to play it once every day.
Katrina: 来就打卡来了
Katrina: Come on, just clock in.
Jack: 哎呀来来来
Jack: Oh, come on, come on.
Katrina: 每天都是了遍普通人
Katrina: Every day, it's for ordinary people.
Katrina: 每天吃吃喝喝弹弹琴睡睡觉
Katrina: Every day, eating, drinking, playing the piano, and sleeping.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah
Jake:因为在做什么
Jake: Because of what?
Katrina: 每天都谈普通朋友
Katrina: Talking with regular friends every day.
Katrina: 一模一样的使
Katrina: Exactly the same.
Shure: 是不是有这个东西我记得
Shure: Is it because of this thing? I remember.
Katrina: 每一天复括
Katrina: Every day, repeat.
Katrina: 好 哥
Katrina: Okay, bro.
Shure: 是不是还有全民K歌
Shure: Is there also the "全民K歌" app?
Jack: 全民k歌
Jack: "全民K歌" app.
Shure: 没事没事来吧
Shure: It's okay, it's okay, let's go.
Shure: 我的我的我的朋友就是
Shure: My, my, my friend is...
Shure: 不是不是不是
Shure: No, no, no.
Shure: 首先有一个我们这个这个
Shure: First of all, we have this, this...
Shure: EGO life大家庭集体要完成的一个任务
Shure: EGO life family has a collective task to complete.
Shure: 叫做哎不是任务给大家
Shure: It's not a task, it's a well-prepared show for everyone.
Shure: 准精心准备的一个节目叫做晴天啊
Shure: It's called "Sunny Day." I'm sure everyone has heard of it.
Shure: 想必大家都听过
Shure: Didn't expect that, right?
Shure: 没错没想到吧
Shure: Yes, didn't expect that.
Katrina: New boy 没排
Katrina: No rehearsal for "New Boy."
Jack: 来吧谁唱谁主唱
Jack: Come on, who's singing the lead?
Jack: 你主唱你就拿着话筒
Jack: You sing the lead, you hold the mic.
Jack: 我拿话筒你
Jack: I'll hold the mic for you.
Nicous: 你拿话筒你
Nicous: You hold the mic.
Shure: 就是
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 那个凳子帮我往前放一点
Shure: Move the chair forward a bit for me.
Katrina: 好一起唱呗
Katrina: Alright, let's sing together.
Shure: 来吧大家会的就一起唱
Shure: Come on, everyone, sing along if you know it.
Katrina: 给你拍个绝美
Katrina: Let me take a perfect picture of you.
Lucia:你要擦那个相机吗还是
Lucia: Do you want to clean the camera or...
Shure: 喂
Shure: Hey
Shure: 完了
Shure: It's over.
Katrina: 好 好听
Katrina: Nice, sounds great.
男嘉宾:少个字
Male Guest: Missing a word.
Jack: 建议拿那个放到词里头
Jack: Suggest putting that into the lyrics.
Katrina: 哎 可以
Katrina: Oh, that works.
Tasha:嗯  好
Tasha: Hmm, okay.
Shure: 对着点我嘴
Shure: Point it towards my mouth.
Shure: 话筒一点升收不进去
Shure: Raise the mic a bit, it's not picking up.
Jack: ok ok说声对不起
Jack: Okay, okay, say sorry.
Shure: 哈哈哈喂喂哎
Shure: Hahaha, hey, hey.
Katrina: 笑死
Katrina: LOL
Jake:哦忘词是吧
Jake: Oh, you forgot the lyrics?
Jake:放词行吗
Jake: Can we display the lyrics?
Jake:啊
Jake: Huh?
Jake:在大屏幕上放词
Jake: Display the lyrics on the big screen.
Katrina: 这是这是
Katrina: This is, this is...
Katrina: 这是彩排啊
Katrina: This is a rehearsal.
Shure: 哈哈哈刚才是试音好吧
Shure: Haha, that was a sound check, alright?
男嘉宾:主要是试音
Male Guest: Mainly a sound check.
Shure: 好吧也也能看到
Shure: Alright, you can see it too.
Katrina: 试音
Katrina: Sound check.
男嘉宾:他这个看不到词
Male Guest: He can't see the lyrics.
男嘉宾:对对对
Male Guest: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Shure: 也也能看到
Shure: You can see it too.
Nicous: 这词有点小
Nicous: The lyrics are a bit small.
男嘉宾:大
Male Guest: Bigger.
男嘉宾:可以可以
Male Guest: It's okay, it's okay.
Shure: 可以看到可以看到啊
Shure: You can see it, you can see it.
男嘉宾:可以看到可以看到
Male Guest: You can see it, you can see it.
Katrina: OK
Katrina: OK.
Katrina: 那你要面对这边面吗
Katrina: Do you want to face this way?
男嘉宾:那你可以重来还是接着来
Male Guest: Do you want to start over or continue?
Shure: 从头来
Shure: Start from the beginning.
男嘉宾:从头来从头来
Male Guest: Start from the beginning, start from the beginning.
Katrina: 好
Katrina: Alright.
Shure: 保证
Shure: Guaranteed.
Katrina: 有勇气
Katrina: Have courage.
Lucia:没事没事这个不是玻璃
Lucia: It's okay, it's okay, this isn't glass.
Shure: 啥玩意碎了
Shure: What broke?
Lucia:这是个啥呀
Lucia: What is this?
女嘉宾:杨老板杨老板
Female Guest: Jake, Jake.
Jake:呃给我给我就好了
Jake: Uh, give it to me, it's fine.
Jake:对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Shure: 下一首还有还有下一首
Shure: Next song, there's another one.
Nicous: 加个钢琴
Nicous: Add a piano.
男嘉宾:还有下一首
Male Guest: There's another song.
Katrina: 你想弹什么你弹
Katrina: Play whatever you want.
Nicous: 前面加一个钢琴
Nicous: Add a piano at the beginning.
Katrina: 来啊
Katrina: Go ahead.
Jack: 可以
Jack: Sure.
Jack: 流沙
Jack: Quicksand
Shure: 我们是不是还说要唱new boy来着啊
Shure: Weren't we planning to sing "New Boy"?
Katrina: 都行都行
Katrina: I'm fine with anything.
Katrina: 反正发现就还是咱几个人
Katrina: Anyway, it's just a few of us here.
男嘉宾:唱什么
Male Guest: What should we sing?
Katrina: 那随便唱
Katrina: Just sing anything.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Let's do it.
Jake:对都在掌握中
Jake: Yeah, we got it all under control.
Jake:你随便唱
Jake: Sing whatever you like.
Katrina: 一切都在掌握中
Katrina: Everything's under control.
Shure: 那个XBZ你
Shure: Hey XBZ, you...
Nicous: 你把麦关了
Nicous: Turn off your mic.
Shure: 你 你弹一个D调的卡农的和弦会吗
Shure: Can you play a D major chord progression of Canon?
Nicous: 可以
Nicous: Sure.
Shure: 不不 你就弹D调卡农和弦就行
Shure: No, no, just play the D major Canon chords.
Katrina: 一切都在掌握中
Katrina: Everything's under control.
Nicous: 很高级
Nicous: Very sophisticated.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 就是
Shure: Exactly.
Katrina: 就么看我房间还是很好看的哈哈
Katrina: My room still looks pretty good, doesn't it? Haha.
Shure: 找一下吧
Shure: Let's look for it.
Shure: 哎呀歌词就行
Shure: Just the lyrics will do.
Shure: 这个
Shure: This one.
Shure: 让大家
Shure: Let everyone...
Jake:对是其他挺费劲的
Jake: Yeah, it's quite a hassle otherwise.
Shure: 能能能找明白不
Shure: Can you find it?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Nicous: 是这个吗
Nicous: Is this the one?
Shure: 差不多吧
Shure: Pretty much.
Shure: 相信你
Shure: I trust you.
刘婷:怎么顶格了
Lucia: Why is it aligned to the top?
Shure: 第一个是这个
Shure: The first one is this.
Shure: 拍什么曲子
Shure: Which song are we shooting?
Jake:哎薇薇呢
Jake: Hey, where's Tasha?
Shure: new boy
Jake:又翘班了
Jake: Skipping work again.
Shure: 好好好
Shure: Okay, okay.
Jake:不行不行
Jake: Not acceptable.
Jake:翘班不行
Jake: Skipping work is not okay.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Jake:得上来摸鱼
Jake: You need to come here and slack off.
Jake:翘班不行
Jake: Skipping work isn't allowed.
Shure: one
Shure: One.
Shure: two
Shure: Two.
Shure: one two three
Shure: One, two, three.
Jake:打电话了 好嘞
Jake: Got a call. Alright.
Tasha:对对
Tasha: Yeah, yeah.
Shure: 打这个是吗
Shure: Call this one, right?
Tasha:我妈妈
Tasha: My mom.
Jake:好啊
Jake: Sure.
Jake:你好你好
Jake: Hello, hello.
Shure: 这个这个
Shure: This one, this one.
Shure: 我从这调
Shure: I'll adjust it from here.
Shure: OK 好
Shure: OK, good.
Jake:好你你忙你忙
Jake: Alright, you go ahead, do your thing.
男嘉宾:喂
Male Guest: Hello?
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Tasha:好
Tasha: Okay.
男嘉宾:还有点大
Male Guest: It's still a bit loud.
Jake:没有没有
Jake: No, no.
男嘉宾:稍为有点大得调小点
Male Guest: It's a little loud, needs to be quieter.
Jake:没有我叫你上去
Jake: No, I told you to come up.
Shure: 好好好
Shure: Alright, alright, alright.
Tasha:叫我上去干嘛
Tasha: Why did you call me up?
Shure: 你的
Shure: Yours.
Jake:上去参加活动
Jake: To join the activity.
Tasha:哦
Tasha: Oh.
Jake:眼镜呢
Jake: Where are the glasses?
Tasha:挂电话了 刚才打电话我放我就放在
Tasha: Hung up the call. I just put them there when I was on the phone.
Jake:啊行行行 好
Jake: Ah, okay, okay, good.
Jake:下去接妈妈的电话去
Jake: Go downstairs to answer your mom's call.
Jake:耶
Jake: Yeah!
Jake:哈哈哈沙雕
Jake: Hahaha, silly.
Jake:来来来
Jake: Come, come, come.
Katrina: 差不多 嗯
Katrina: Almost, yeah.
Shure: 行了行了行了可以了可以了
Shure: Alright, alright, alright, that's enough, that's enough.
Katrina: 哈哈哈谱还没对象
Katrina: Hahaha, still no partner.
Katrina: 结束了
Katrina: It's over.
Shure: 来吧你你的难忘今宵了吧该
Shure: Come on, your unforgettable night, right?
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Jack: 啊 谁难忘今宵了
Jack: Ah, who can't forget tonight?
Nicous: 那你调下声
Nicous: Then adjust the sound.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Shure: 人呢还有一个
Shure: Where's the other person?
Shure: 还有一个XBZ同学要为大家带来的一首歌曲
Shure: There's another student, XBZ, who will perform a song for everyone.
Shure: 叫
Shure: Called
Nicous: 谢彬竹和修硕的
Nicous: By Xie Binzhu and Shure.
Shure: 没有我没有我
Shure: Not me, not me.
Nicous: 你这比我重要了
Nicous: You're more important than me.
Shure: 这个
Shure: This one.
Shure: 我比你重要什么
Shure: How am I more important than you?
Shure: 我给你选一个好听的音色就好了
Shure: I'll just pick a nice tone for you.
Nicous: 给我切换一下
Nicous: Switch it for me.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Nicous: 用手指切换
Nicous: Switch with your finger.
Shure: 来吧XBZ同学
Shure: Come on, student XBZ.
Shure: 没有他
Shure: He's not here.
Katrina: 呵呵 这弹出来
Katrina: Haha, this popped out.
男嘉宾:有点想哭了 音乐出来就想哭
Male Guest: I feel like crying, the music makes me want to cry.
Katrina: 这是背景音吧
Katrina: Is this background music?
男嘉宾:这加了特效音乐
Male Guest: This has special effects music added.
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: Oh.
Katrina: 天呐 如听仙乐耳在鸣哈哈
Jack: 准备 准准备开哭
Jack: Get ready, get ready to cry.
Katrina: 这什么歌
Katrina: What song is this?
男嘉宾:难忘今宵
Male Guest: Unforgettable Tonight.
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Shure: 今夜我们在此欢聚
Shure: Tonight we gather here with joy.
Alice:我靠
Alice: Oh my god.
男嘉宾:哎哟喂
Male Guest: Oh wow.
Katrina: 受不了了
Shure: 今夜我们在此快乐
Shure: Tonight we are happy here.
Nicous: 再再来一点
Nicous: Do it again, a bit more.
男嘉宾:已经开饮一天了
Male Guest: We've been drinking all day.
Alice:这什么环节啊
Alice: What part is this?
Katrina: 忘记今宵
Katrina: Forget Tonight.
Shure的女友:难忘今宵
Shure: Unforgettable Tonight.
Jake:赶上clothing了
Jake: We're catching up with the clothing.
Shure: 我们相聚一堂
Shure: We are gathered together.
Shure: 在这ego house
Shure: Here at the ego house
Jack: 什么呀
Jack: What are you talking about?
Alice:有点抽象
Alice: It's a bit abstract.
Jake:我跟你哈哈哈哈
Jake: Haha, I'm with you.
Jack: 顺间就服气了
Jack: Instantly impressed.
女嘉宾:你们坐吧
Female Guest: You guys sit down.
Alice:哦对我的衣服没晾哦
Alice: Oh right, I didn't hang my clothes.
Shure: 我们难忘今宵
Shure: We'll never forget tonight.
Shure: 我们难忘未来
Shure: We will never forget the future.
Jack: 难忘未来什么
Jack: What do you mean by never forget the future?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈你忘什么东西
Jake: Haha, what did you forget?
男嘉宾:我笑死了
Male Guest: I'm dying of laughter.
Katrina: 还没过呢就难忘
Katrina: It's not even over yet and you're saying never forget.
Shure: 我们难忘过去
Shure: We will never forget the past.
Katrina: 好夺目啊
Katrina: So dazzling.
Shure: 来吧 朋友
Shure: Come on, friend.
Jake:快进门
Jake: Hurry, come in.
Shure: 牵着你的手
Shure: Holding your hand.
女嘉宾:要退票了
Female Guest: I want a refund.
Shure: 就让
Shure: Just let...
Shure: 昨天的烦恼都忘掉
Shure: Forget all the worries of yesterday.
Jake:傻瓜
Jake: Fool.
Shure: 去迎接明天的快乐吧
Shure: Embrace the happiness of tomorrow.
Katrina: 在做心灵SPA啊
Katrina: Doing a spiritual spa.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah...
Jack: 还啊的一声
Jack: And you even said "ah".
Shure: 多好啊
Shure: How wonderful.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Nicous: 我有点感觉这个谱子不太对啊
Nicous: I feel like this tune isn't quite right.
Shure: 挺好的
Shure: It's fine.
男嘉宾:没有
Male Guest: No, it's not.
Jake:这叫离谱你懂吗
Jake: This is what you call "off the charts", you know?
Shure: 这个我们就叫做离谱对吧
Shure: We call this "off the charts", right?
Jack: 没有
Jack: No.
Jack: 滚你这看起来就不算有谱不能叫离谱
Jack: Get lost, this doesn't even count as a chart to be "off the charts".
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Nicous: 他没有背歌词
Nicous: He didn't memorize the lyrics.
Nicous: 他在玩茶流鸡我草
Nicous: He's just winging it, damn.
Jack: 让我猜他己经醉了
Jack: Let me guess, he's already drunk.
Jake:哈哈已经唱完了
Jake: Haha, he's already done singing.
Shure: 没有没有我们这就是诗朗诵环节
Shure: No no, this is our poetry recitation segment.
Jake:哎好好好
Jake: Okay okay.
Shure: 难忘今宵表演者
Shure: Unforgettable Tonight, performed by
Shure: Ego life全体成员
Shure: All members of Ego Life.
Jake:啥 哈哈
Jake: What? Haha.
Katrina: 立的都爬了
Katrina: Everyone's climbing up.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
男嘉宾:所以所以你们这一个礼拜
Male Guest: So, so you guys, this whole week...
女嘉宾:退票
Female Guest: Refunded tickets.
男嘉宾:都是天天这么精神病吗
Male Guest: Have you been this crazy every day?
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure: 新来的朋友啊
Shure: New friends, huh?
Shure: 我们每天都很快乐
Shure: We're happy every day.
Shure: 来吧快来到美好的ego life吧
Shure: Come on, join the wonderful Ego Life.
Jack: 美好啊是没有好那个好吧
Jack: Wonderful, as in not good?
Shure: ego life是一个
Shure: Ego Life is a...
Shure: 快乐的大家庭
Shure: Happy big family.
Shure: 是一个没有纷争的大家庭
Shure: A big family with no conflicts.
Shure: 是一个完蛋
Shure: It’s a... oh no.
Shure: 我被美女包围了的大家庭
Shure: A big family where I’m surrounded by beauties.
Shure: Ego life
Shure: Ego Life.
Jack: 就这句话比较现实
Jack: That's the most realistic part.
Shure: 带给了我快乐
Shure: It brings me joy.
Katrina: 这是诗歌朗诵
Katrina: This is a poetry recitation.
Shure: 带给了我金币
Shure: It brings me gold coins.
Jake:Ego Coin
Jake: Ego Coin.